hi there Steve Kaufman today I want to
talk about language hacks hacking
language learning it's very fashionable
to talk about hacking things hacking I
know there's a self-help site called
life hacks full of advice on how to tie
your shoelaces faster and stuff what do
I think about language hacks hacking
language learning I have to say that and
I'm I should say that you DS do see
articles on how to hack the subjunctive
or Hackley imperfect or hack Chinese
characters and I I don't like the word
hack because the word hack to me
suggests something destructive somebody
coming in and destroying my computer
I don't believe really in shortcuts but
if we just take the word to mean you
know tips I think every language learner
develops his or her own habits and some
of us like to share them here on the
internet as I do and so perhaps their
hacks if I look at at my three sort of
golden keys of language learning we
could call them hacks so hack number one
is to to have a positive attitude to
enjoy the process to to do things that
you enjoy doing so one hack might be to
stop going over the same boring learner
content that you're not really
interested in just in the hope that
somehow is helping your language
learning do things that you find
interesting get on to compelling content
as stephen krashen says so in a sense
that's a hacked gets you to enjoy the
process makes you more positive the
second key of course is to spend enough
time so here again the hack where the
shortcut is that there is no shortcut
it's going to take you a long time but
if you follow the first hack and do
things that are enjoyable then you don't
mind spending the time you're not
anxious to to have a short cut of a
process that you find enjoyable so try
to make it enjoy
and then you'll spend the time and the
third hack would have to do with this my
third key which is developing that
attentiveness the ability to notice and
hear there's different things we can do
obviously just massive exposure makes
you more attentive to the language if
you're paying attention
occasionally reviewing the grammar makes
you more attentive but the main focus
again is on this it's massive input in
my view when I read and listen I try to
notice I underline when I read I save
links in link you know all of these
things I think I'd never expect to learn
like a review I might review some
grammar rules or some examples I don't
expect to remember all of that but I do
believe that it makes me a little more
attentive and when we're learning you
know if the text is difficult for me
that I'm focused mostly on an
understanding of them and saving words
in link and try to understand what's
being said and sometimes I don't fully
understand it but if I'm motivated to
get through that content I'll continue
to plow through it even though there are
a lot of new words to me on the other
hand when I'm reading something that's
easier for me then I'll make a conscious
effort to try to notice certain
constructions that I know I have a
problem with because that increases my
ability to notice my attentiveness and
if you notice again and again eventually
you develop new habits and you start to
sort of ingest the language and develop
the language habits that you want so
there you have it my take on language
hacks I don't think there are real
language hat hacks I think we have to
develop our own special you know
activities that we enjoy doing thank you
for listening bye for now